hello reject nation and good evening
India I am Greg Alba I am John old we
are going to watch the glass official
trailer numero dos the most anticipated
January movie of all time right here and
as a heads up or doing a little
experiment here since you know we like
to really review our trailers and and
whatnot we're gonna be doing our trailer
review on a separate video so you can
hit the link right after this reaction
is done if you care to watch that we
know some people just watch your
reactions but you know whatever it's it
so might be a one-off let's find out
before we do that I wanted to give a
quick thank you to everyone who's been
following us at our patreon page yep
over there we do TV show reactions for
many as show some already completed what
we're currently watching now are some
anime like attack on Titan my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and some live action right
now Gotham Riverdale and supernatural
and some weekly Q&A backtrack a little
bit
speaking of supernatural glass let's do
it
[Music]
[Music]
I'm here to see if tales of the
extraordinary
I need someone who require your full
attention oh my
you might want to join us
a lot of people are going to die oh wait
a minute like a PB and J sandwich
what have you done how much I love that
shot at what they're both flying in the
air and then the glass oh yeah oh yeah
it is so cool it's just way too cool
it's too cool it's too sick man it's too
sick this movie shouldn't be made no -
cool let's take it back let's ungainly
this Shelby forever and never seen it
alright guys well we have a lot of
thoughts on this I imagine so logo gonna
go do a trailer review for it right now
make sure to go check out that video
meantime you can subscribe the reject
nation check us out on patreon and click
that notification bell yo